كثرا يعتقدون ان الشهادات الجامعيه غير
مهمه ليصبح الشخص ثريا ويستدلون بمؤسس
فيسبوك
الذي لم يكمل تعليمه الجامعي لكن هذا ليس
بالضروره صحيحا فهناك العديد من
المليونيرات بل المليارديرات الذين اصبحوا
اغنياء وفي حوزتهم شهادات دكتوره وهناك
تخصصات محدده هي الاكثر جذبا للاثرياء
تقرير جديد لصحيفه
لم يبداوا بتاسيس اعمالهم او جمع ثروتهم
قبل ذيل شهاده دكتوره الصحيفه تصنفات اكثر
من خمسه تخصصات مرغوبه لهم بدايه بالهندسه
التي تراست القائمه ثم علوم الكمبيوتر وفي
المرتبه الثالثه جاءت الاحياء تليها
الكيمياء والفيزياء ورغم ان نسبه هؤلاء لا
تتجاوز خمسه في المئه من اغنياء امريكا
الا ان ثروتهم مجتمعه تصل الى 165 مليار
دولار ما رايكم هل هناك علاقه بين الشهاده
الجام عيه وجمع الثروات